Khloe Kardashian says 2017 was one of
the best years of her life it was fun
[Music]
the Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
penned an end-of-the-year blog post on
her app and reflected on the past 12
months quote so many incredible things
happened and lots of good memories now
we are taking a look back at khlo
money's 2017 Kardashian calendar
the reality star rang in the New Year
with her man NBA pro Tristan Thompson in
February they enjoyed a romantic
jamaican getaway then vacate in Palm
Springs with Kim and Kourtney celebrated
her boyfriends birthday and changed her
last name from Odom back to Kardashian
in April she celebrated ten years of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians with
cake rows a and naturally a photo booth
Tristan surprised her on her birthday in
June and in July
Khloe hosted a killer Independence Day
party
in September et learned Coco is
expecting her first child with Tristan
what the next month coca met with a
young cancer patient won best couples
costume on Halloween and her family
reportedly re signed a deal with E for
one hundred and fifty million dollars in
November Chloe hid her baby bump and
attended Kim's baby shower and hit the
road for a junk-food filled girls trip
with her sisters Coco celebrated
Thanksgiving in Cleveland Ohio with her
man Coco and in December she shared this
smooch filled snapshot writing the day I
met you my life changed
[Music]